منذ لحظات فقط سمعنا صفارات الإنذار
تنطلق فوق تل أبيب، وبينما كنا على
الهواء مباشرة تم اعتراض الصواريخ بواسطة
القبة الحديدية في إسرائيل، شاهد
هذا بدأ يهطل والآن
بدأنا نسمع صفارات الإنذار أه أنا
سألتزم الصمت  لثانية واحدة حتى تتمكن من سماع
ما يحدث عادة هو أنك
ستبدأ إذا كان هناك صاروخ قادم تسمع
أه صوت القبة الحديدية
تحاول اعتراض ذلك الصاروخ أه هذا
ثاني يوم أو ليلة على التوالي  لقد
حصلت اه أوه هناك حريق التتبع
لا أعرف إذا كان يمكننا تشغيل الكاميرا
أم أرى يا إلهي هناك واحد آخر
هناك واحد آخر آه تعال
إلي هنا أم هناك
واحد آخر فوق رؤوسنا مباشرة
فوق رؤوسنا  اتجه هنا، لقد اختفى للتو
خلف
سحب [الموسيقى] أوه، إنه فوقنا
تمامًا، نحن نراه
فوق رؤوسنا مباشرةً ولم أسمع ذلك
الصوت الذي نسمعه عادةً
لاستجابة القبة الحديدية لكننا جوم نحن  رأيت للتو
إطلاق ما يبدو أنه من
القبة الحديدية تحاول
اعتراضه، هناك
صوت آخر من
أجهزة إنذار سيارة مزدهرة تنطلق الآن،
وهذا يحدث لأنه
يهزها، هناك واحد
حسنًا هناك، هناك
انظر، هناك اثنان هناك أربعة ثلاثة
أربعة خمسة هناك خمسة قادمون
الآن، هل يمكنكم أن تحضروا لي خوذتي يا رفاق من فضلكم،
هناك خمسة مختلفين، هناك
حريق قادم من
القبة الحديدية يحاول اعتراض الصواريخ، ستسمعون دويًا قادمًا،
سترون  الضوء الذي
ترى الومضات وترى الضوء
أولاً ينتقل الضوء بشكل أسرع من الصوت
بالطبع يجب أن تسمع دويًا
قريبًا،
سأظل هادئًا هنا فقط
لانتظار هذا الصوت هناك، وآمل أن يكون هناك
اعتراض هناك  هذا واحد
رأينا خمسة يتذكرونه، لذلك يجب أن يكون هناك
زوجين، وهناك آخر آخر، وهذا
خمسة، ويجب أن يكون هناك آخر، وهذا
ستة، وسارة الحمد لله على ما يرام، فقد
ارتدت خوذتها بعد فترة من الوقت، وهو
موقف مخيف للغاية، تذكر أن تل أبيب
هي أكبر مدن إسرائيل
مدينة